and we'll Brian's trying to copy your
haircut yeah he's gonna have to you can
stick your goodbye and I can see the
crowd here that's nice
well have what I have 17 hairs on the
top of my head and my old man used to
have something we called Tony island you
know okay well I have more than that so
I have more than that
sure now man okay well don't be shitty
now granted we made funnier hair pretty
hardcore and a lot of people did online
lot chicks did get me huh I've been
getting a lot of female fans telling me
that they like my hair every female fan
loves it every male fan hates it well I
don't think they hate it it's just easy
to make fun of
that's one cat when I walk I'd be crying
you look good too that one looks good
today
again cat appreciate your positive
attitude way to bring that today here's
the thing though cat short she's looking
up like this she can't get through the
[ __ ] show at the top you're looking down
and she doesn't see that you look like
Jason Statham shitty older brother
yeah no I'm saying yeah there's a little
bit of a you're getting a different
angle see it all depends on what angle
you look at somebody for I get all it
haven't you dated girls where they look
amazing from one angle and then you seem
from another and it's like oh no a Sun
hits their face and they look like
[ __ ] Hulk Hogan had a beard problem I
had that with the you know I'm talking
about I don't I saw a certain actress
who I used to be obsessed with and I saw
her from the side I think we talked
about this but she had a mustache like a
monster 97 saw my very pretty hugged
Iran if you see her from the side hater
show her from her chin no I gotta be a
god bless her very beautiful very sexy
she's just got a straw like a strong
chin and I do too and I didn't know it's
right here they're right here looks a
little a little bit Irish if you saw it
was shown her short hair and that it was
it was an unflattering look like short
hair otherwise she's gorgeous she should
and I'm being wrong gotiya yeah I don't
like being mean he's so hot yes she's
course I'll dude her and [ __ ] dust
till dawn Oh Santa when I was a young
strapping lad I
jacket to that thing she's beautiful I
like that gender I like everything about
her I'm just hate her I'm just saying
for me I have I have a specific now I
saw on that leap Ortman with a shaved
head and I would walk over what is that
bam bam
I don't know it's just like show stop
look at her they're smokin look at that
scene of all time Lebanese Mexican then
you get that thick snake around her neck
that's a good movie I want to watch that
it doesn't hold up have you watched it
lately
mm it's pretty cheesy she's so [ __ ]
bad oh yeah oh and there's a vampire oh
you're wrong I say it doesn't hold up
it's a little cheesy but man is it good
it's entertaining
she's those are everything about that is
real she's so delicious yeah but no you
don't know you said her face is funny so
I look whatever
well just from a certain angle when she
was doing Frieda with that hair of
course it was a unibrow no problem she
was shooting that doe so I your boy your
boy seal came over he saw I was inviting
my holidays right it doesn't have any
family here yeah so he came over for
Easter
he doesn't realize that TT is full of
energy
he's 24/7 and he likes to wrestle
everybody that comes through that
goddamn door whether it's his grandpa
whoever did yield wrestling
feels not that much of a physical person
a kid person problem no he's not bad
he's really good with he's really good
with Tiger but Tiger will chunk the [ __ ]
out of you so Tiger does back and most
yanked his wig off yeah you just not
stop he's crazy it's like damn ants why
kids are like I know this for me like
that won't Tigers different breed dude
Tigers I go TT seals not gonna play with
anymore cuz you're too rough you're just
too rough dude you're rough with
everybody just Papa were rough like we
are off he's I remember when the ball
got thrown on his face really hard by
accident and he didn't cry and every
other kid would cry with that you did
that to my son now at 18 strike nobody
rode his bike with me three miles wide
three miles what three miles at four
four years old three miles didn't walk
didn't stop three miles crash
that he loves that hike loves you want
know us brother test bro lets us we took
blood test cool so I don't live together
then well got together so it mean
nothing especially when Brian I gotta
see a [ __ ] video of him [ __ ] putz
around with but bas Rutten yeah [ __ ] it
Oakland that's the point well [ __ ]
dude
well you know so here's the thing well
here's the thing though if we get it
we're fine
you're fine I'm guessing you don't have
any well there's one in the [ __ ]
directly in the screen but do you have
any LDS Brian just Brian is that zero
Bravo listen up sunshine how old are
your parents I don't they're in Denver
hey do you like the best whiskey in the
world it's the best moustache you drink
whiskey yeah the best whiskey in the
world right I want to get a couple of
things that annoy me already
Brent we just started Brent Brent the
problem with the name like Brent is it's
the same name as Craig no it's not
that's Greg or Craig don't be Brett
dread or Brent well yelling don't be
either one of those names maybe change
and also you have a mustache okay first
off don't compare me to a Craig or Greg
all right Brent is exotic there's
something about him orco he's a rich
[ __ ] you don't know who he is
well two different white guys or a fun
black guy there are no black diamond
that's a great black guy yeah I've never
met her but I don't think there's a
black guy in the world named Brent yes
when give me one to junior high school
with to Brent's I don't think so black
one was half black
don't say boy you said it at night Long
Beach we I'm from Connecticut so that
doesn't scream dude that's a that's what
are you doing five hundred hours where
the whiskey are we sippin
all right you're a little out of hand
yeah you
Sebastian asked off the guys out of hand
get yours cling keys [ __ ] man cling keys
it's the best whiskey in the world I'm
not joking tomorrow hey thanks to my to
my Corona homies we got a Corona homies
dude I think Corona
I think the mustache sometimes a Corona
makes sense
it's nothing else to do a thought about
filter I thought about it the filter is
really good wow that is you want us
closer yeah
six feet bro well I like this I deleted
since we all know Thalia very well here
yeah Thalia did Rogen's podcast and he
went to the thing and of course Rogan
does a three-hour podcast I got there
just in time and I should have gotten
there earlier cuz guess who ran out of
[ __ ] things to say Chris Chris D'Elia
well yeah yup and guess who ran an
energy he just goes yep and one point I
looked him I went oh you just you just
lost everything he goes I got hungry I'm
hungry
three hours is too long Chris yeah no
staying power
he'll said it best he did Rogen and the
first time do Rowan calling us he was
umbrella I don't talk to my dad long in
three hours that's aweso I were talking
me with my life all they wanted yeah I
don't have an attention span like that
either I never get tired when I talk to
oh no three hours no we did three hours
and 30 minutes I think they thought
that's because I'm deep and I'm
expansive in my knowledge yeah I'm
talking about like stuff it's like very
it I remember one time I hung out with
you and of Davidoff yeah and we went out
to it for a drink the three of us yeah
you two just talked about pygmies yeah
wait for and I'm talking about
philosophy and you were looking and
Jason it was like this he's like this
and then and then tough goes hey stop
talking about this [ __ ] the guy's not
interested in you never said talk about
this stuff does great yeah it's great
pushed a warm bottle of milk in your
mouth remember that yeah and honestly
Rona man yeah no thanks dad
don't make him say don't ever do it I
like me I wasn't
Brian app and then that's done and then
$10 I rise right away I gotta hear about
a lot of people that brush it on man
yeah it was it was on there it was great
I was on there but I was at the Comedy
Store one night and I let I let you know
the waitresses there that worked there
they're all friends you know they just
wanted to see what it was like and it's
my fault that I gave my phone and said
yeah whatever you could look at it and
then they just wrote like some funny
thing I think this is what I think why
the next day I was banned but then I
guess somebody wrote like I like pizza
in my butthole to some girl like just
some jealous and I guess it was enough
that got me banned where I'm like okay
then fine I'm banned all right that's
done whatever now I have to walk around
Hollywood wondering who was it and did
that spread like are people gonna be
like oh there's bread cuz I don't know
who it was kicked off on riot feel a
little dirty like a dick pic he's not
creepy
I write to say hi I know what an
original start in parentheses is all I
write to start so I was like you could
just do some evidence and see that I'm
not writing that type of [ __ ] so but
after that tinder they won't believe
it's me which is [ __ ] crazy cuz I'm
not famous like that's that doesn't work
but I can't get laid on their Sofia now
is it bumble - I [ __ ] hate those apps
what about fahren I meet someone in
person yeah but here's the problem
farmers only I want on a farm is only
day and it was like seven acres was a
driveway and then no one was there just
a bunch of pumpkins on fire no the
quarantine you can't date like there's
nothing to do so I'm just with my
thoughts sketching yeah brilliant things
I stopped then some stuff I [ __ ] up on
is the dead cuz just take a piss we're
in the hot tub and I pee and there's
yellow and he was hits in the hot tubs
my hot tub his chlorine you just pissin
please and hot tubs so IP not to be as
popular I can pee in the hot tub you can
pee the hot tub my girls hold on no he
can't
why not she owes he's he got his friends
it's not say urine yeah but it's my pool
and there's tons of chemicals kill I
don't care
don't piss in your food or peed in the
pool no I don't ever know I don't piss
and pool oh oh I'm sorry you just died
when I went to the beach with them
double hole yeah old peace out
yeah pissed in the same [ __ ] I'm not
gonna piss in the goddamn [ __ ] you
know it's my pool oh my gosh I but my
girls were brought up a good point she
does know he can't I go who Campion the
pool there's chemicals it's fine I got
pee in the pool before she does
here's the prom Brent I didn't think she
was he's in good his friend's house
gonna be at school and they go to a pool
thing and he's gonna piss in and all the
kids are like oh that's right in pools I
didn't think of that
yeah and you just piss in a pool hall
it's my pool and piss in your [ __ ]
hot tub welcome to just your poor hot
tub you would piss in anyone's with this
little king of countries yeah just under
this piss that annoys me about you
really give that to you as it's a gift
it's a gift